all right welcome everybody to session
six of our ongoing understanding anger
2.0 and for anybody who's unfamiliar
with this why the 2.0 I did a series
years back in person called
understanding anger at the Kingston
public library and each session focused
on a literary or religious or
philosophical tradition thinker set of
texts and we looked at how anger played
itself out in that and then I taught
um three sections over the last year at
Marquette University of a class Focus
specifically on anger and so you know
people had the idea that maybe we could
restart the understanding anger so
that's exactly what we're doing
understanding anger 2.0 is of course as
you see here web-based and has the
potential to go on for years and years
we've already done
five sessions the first one kind of
introductory we did two sessions on
Plato and you know we may come back to
him in the future we did another session
on Homer's Iliad and how anger plays out
in that and then we looked at Hessian
works and days the theogony and a few
other works as well and now we're doing
something a little bit different we're
going to be talking about Aristotle this
session and the following session and
this session we're just going to be
talking after I do a little bit of
introductory stuff about Aristotle about
his work the the art of rhetoric which
provides us with a very in-depth
discussion analysis you could say of
what anger is and how it works as an
emotion and then next time so next month
in August we will be doing session seven
where we'll look at Aristotle's
discussion of anger in other works like
the nickel McCann and udamian ethics
topics in a few places on the soul and
the politics and will be you know sort
of integrating this account and you
might say well why split it up like that
because
um there's so much in the rhetoric that
we can spend an entire session on it
and I kind of want to uh you know
distinguish between different ways of
looking at anger as we're going to talk
about that I think Aristotle is very
helpful with so a bit of General stuff
before we get into the rhetoric as such
about Aristotle
um you know if you if you're familiar
with him this will be old hat if you're
not or you're kind of marginally
familiar with them this might be very
helpful Aristotle is one of those
thinkers who is a polymath has a
literally omnivorous curiosity he wants
to study everything that he can and he's
going to be treating anger in a a way
like that he's going to look at it from
a bunch of different angles
and so he
writes a number of works that fit in
with what we you know associate with
philosophy we think of him as a very
important philosopher right
um you know like the metaphysics the
ethics The Logical works but he also
writes political science literary
criticism rhetoric as we're going to see
psychology uh physics and biology that
stuff we kind of think is is outmoded
even household management uh if the
economics is by Aristotle and his
approach to things is what we call
dialectical now it's not dialectical on
the hegelian or Marxist or later senses
it's dialectical in the sense that
Aristotle thinks that you see what
before you start talking yourself about
what other people uh or what what your
your own theory is you see whether
anybody else has something useful to
contribute about it and you know that's
what he does he incorporates those
things into his own position so you're
often going to see him saying well you
know some people think this and some
people think this let's take a look at
that he's also more empirical or
observational than you know say Plato
his his teacher
um you know universals we can certainly
talk about them but they exist out there
in the world and phenomena so if we're
talking about anger and felt it's the
same thing but it's not as if there's
like a platonic form of anger out there
another thing I think is really cool
about Aristotle and I find quite
admirable is that he doesn't try to come
up with a theory of everything he thinks
that you got different subject matters
and you gotta you know develop your
theory for them uh around the the things
that are most key most germane most
revealing so he you could say he
respects the irreducibility of different
kinds or ranges or types of beings to
each other not everything can be reduced
to the psychological or to the ethical
or to the metaphysical right and he has
a an anthropology which is not
completely developed granted
um Aristotle would say
we are bodily beings as human beings and
we're not just reducible to our bodies
we have this thing that is called a soul
but it's not something like a platonic
or Cartesian or Christian soul that can
exist apart from the body the soul is
the form of the body it is the the
principle of life right it's what makes
you a living thing lacking that you
become medical waste
were also beings whose Souls have parts
or Dimensions that we can distinguish
apart from each other and so you know we
have higher and lower parts to our souls
and this for Aristotle is associated
with our animality
um lower and are distinctively human
rational nature on the higher and they
interpenetrate each other in very
complicated ways another really key
thing for Aristotle is that we are
social and communicative beings We Exist
not as isolated substances you know
apart from each other who then happen to
come together we are by our very nature
um by the time that we even start
thinking about things we're connected
with other people so that's that's
important to keep in mind now Aristotle
in the west is
really the first person to come up with
what we could call a philosophical and
even scientific approach to the
phenomenon of anger people had been
thinking about anger getting angry for
centuries and centuries before Aristotle
and there's a lot
um to be you know said in Plato and in
these you know poets and other people as
well but
they thought about anger
um but not so much in truly general
terms for its own sake and in philosophy
uh with Aristotle with Plato before him
too
um inquiry is being carried out more
systematically and there's you know
attention being paid to making the
portions of an overall account in a fit
be internally coherent with each other
so Aristotle wants to provide us with an
understanding of the causes the nature
the workings and the effects of anger
and he also wants to look at anger as a
moral or ethical phenomenon now he
doesn't actually write a book on anger
as some later authors will do you might
keep in mind like seneca's on anger
coming centuries later there was
actually an Aristotelian called
Hieronymus
Jerome who wrote a lost treaties on
anger that's reference but we don't we
don't have it so we don't actually know
what the guy wrote
um but you know
Aristotle is giving us something that we
can kind of piece together as an account
of this emotion and we can learn a lot
from
now
um I brought up the term scientific and
if there's people who are thinking in
terms of modern you know Western uh
science they might say well Aristotle's
not really scientific in that way
science means a lot of different things
and to be scientific
um in part means to
um you know focus on understanding how
things actually work why they are the
way that they are doing so in a
systematic way doesn't have necessarily
anything to do with experimentation or
stuff like that that's a later
understanding and it's a term that we
encounter in Greek as episime in Latin
as guilletia and a genuinely scientific
Viewpoint avoids oversimplifying you
know Occam's razor is not something you
should be wielding around all over the
place and lopping stuff off whether we
want to joke around about it you want to
have an adequate account of things and
you know it's not as if experimentation
or you know observation can't play any
role
that's part of what we do right and
Aristotle himself is going to as I
mentioned look at Anger from a number of
different perspectives so
Aristotle distinguishes himself between
at least three different ways to look at
matters like anger so there's the way
that a natural scientist or medical
doctor a foosikos a person who's
interested in in bodies and how they
interact he says in on the soul that the
way the person looks at that is also on
the topics if I remember right is
different than the way that a
philosopher who's interested in human
Affairs and beliefs and actions and
argument a dialecticos would look at it
and in the rhetoric the book that we're
going to be looking at today we're
taking also a different perspective
we're thinking about how would somebody
who's trying to engage in persuasive
communication
how would they use knowledge about the
way the emotions work and specifically
anger and so the the rhetorician is
looking at things in a different way
than say the ethicist and each of these
perspectives is connected with but not
reducible to the others so you know we
have bodies and our bodies do feel anger
in our bodies but that's that's not
enough to explain what's going on in
persuasive communication or in moral
judgment or anything like that I
actually distinguish between six
different perspectives in Aristotle's
text through which he examines anger and
we can talk about that in the Q a later
if we want to so
um what else is really distinctive
before we get to the rhetoric to the
Aristotelian approach
one of the things that's actually coming
out of the rhetoric book one Aristotle
is very interested in what makes people
do the things they do right and uh
choice is is part of that but there's
all sorts of other factors as well and
he says that uh thumos or Oregon both of
which are words for anger
he says that this is one of the main
kinds of human AFF activity our feelings
right our desires our drives and he
lists off seven different fundamental
causes for Human Action in the rhetoric
anger is one of those that's how
important it is to him and interestingly
what else do we see with Aristotle
that's you know left out for example in
the stoics later on and some Christian
authors
Aristotle thinks that anger can serve a
useful purpose it's it we could have a
positive or at least neutral moral
valuation of anger in some cases and
there's virtues and vices associated
with that and we're going to talk about
that more next time right
he also pays a lot of attention to what
actually makes people angry how does
this work right and what intensifies it
what lessens it
um he's got also got a view of anger as
in some way connected with what we could
call practical rationality how we think
out what we ought to do right and maybe
more so than other emotions or desires
angers kind of complicated that way he
actually in nickel McCain ethics book
Seven says that anger is like a hasty
servant it listens to some of the things
that are said and then it synergizes it
reasons about what it ought to do and
again we'll talk about that more next
time so um what about the rhetoric so
what what are we actually looking at
here in rhetoric book two the very first
emotion that Aristotle discusses
is anger and then he talks about its
opposite calmness priorities in in Greek
as we're going to talk about
and he gives us a definition of anger
now the definition is complex it's got a
lot of moving parts so we're gonna have
to unpack it so I'm going to read the
definition at you real quick and then
we'll go and look at each of these parts
so what is anger a desire accompanied by
pain for apparent retribution aroused by
an apparent sliding against oneself or
those connected to oneself the sliding
being undeserved right so let's look at
each of these in turn so it's a desire
an orexis IT orients us towards doing
something and what is it a desire for
for Retribution for uh setting things
right for punishing for Revenge there's
lots of different ways to translate this
word
timoresis which comes from the word
teame honor right and it involves this
this this
imposing something
on others he will also use uh making
suffer in return the desire could be
that in
um the topics he uh he talks about it
that way in books four and seven
um so we've got a desire right a desire
oriented towards something towards
retribution now
I want to point something out apparent
retribution we're going to come back to
that apparent word in just a moment but
let's talk about some of the other
factors so a desire for Retribution and
now he talks about how it's caused what
brings this desire into being aroused by
an apparent sliding so we're going to
get to sliding in a minute and keep that
thing about a parent in your back pocket
as well sliding uh is is doing something
you know to to somebody else but is it
only against oneself it could be against
oneself but it could also be against
those who are connected to oneself
in Greek right those who we care about
those who we feel connected with like
our our spouses our our significant
others our parents our children it could
extend to people that we care about that
we don't even know like somebody's
making fun of a musician that I've you
know I listened to but I've never
actually seen let alone interacted with
I could get angry on their behalf
so now we've got a lot of moving Parts
already right we know the direction that
anger is going we understand what's
causing it but there's more to the cause
so the sliding
um is uh against people you know it's
against ourselves for those that we we
care about
um and the sliding has to be viewed as
undeserved
contos as being inappropriate as being
wrong as being unjust so if we think
that we actually deserve the treatment
that people are giving us you know like
we know we did something wrong and
they're punishing us and we agree with
it then we don't get angry we feel other
emotions instead like sadness or shame
or stuff like that if we think that it's
undeserved that's when we get angry we
get riled up now there's one other
element that I didn't get to in that
definition
and that is accompanied by pain metal
lupus accompanied by disturbance by
grief by something that bothers us so
pain starts the anger but anger is
something painful to feel
he's also going to talk about pleasure
as being involved in Anger for many
people and in many cases as well so
um we you know we we take pleasure in
imposing the retribution or and in
anticipating and hoping for it literally
and he's got this phrase that comes from
The Iliad anger sweeter than honey
dripping from the comb right
so this is a lot going on here there's
one other element that I said to like
hold on to a parent find nominees so in
ancient Greek
phynominase can mean apparent public it
can also mean imaginary because Fantasia
phynomite these are connected together
that's our faculty of imagination so if
you can be satisfied with writing
something mean about somebody in social
media Media or maybe making a video
about them or you know whatever that can
be retribution it's totally imaginary
right because they're you're not
actually affecting them they'll probably
never see it you could even like write a
angry email or a letter and not send it
that could count as a parent retribution
and then the sliding can be apparent too
we can get angry over stuff that doesn't
even really exist
um so you know we can get angry watching
a television show at the villain doing
something to the family of the hero that
we've identified with right or you see
you know celebrities
um who are kind of real people but also
I mean their Public Image is not a
reality right people will say something
mean about them Elon Musk isn't as smart
as people think he is oh I'm angry at
you for that how dare you say something
bad about the guy that I love so much
you know that's that's purely imaginary
right uh they didn't actually slight you
they just slided the public image of
somebody that you think is is a cool guy
so there's a lot involved in this
definition I do want to say a few other
things and we'll do a little q a just to
make sure that we're like on track so
sliding what is this
in Greek it's oligoria which means sort
of like making something less and so
sliding is tied to our
sort of views on ourself and where we
fit in with other people Aristotle
defines it as making real an opinion so
energia doing something doc say Stokes
is opinion about something appearing to
be valueless or worthless or to be worth
less than we we think it is so you know
if I uh one of the examples we're going
to look at later on if I forget your
name then you feel like I'm sliding you
uh you feel like I'm treating you as if
you don't matter as if you're not worth
something whereas I may have just you
know I may be bad with names I have a
hard time remembering people's names and
Aristotle will talk about three main
modes of sliding so one of these is what
we translate as disdain or contempt
depending on the translation another is
spitefulness or malice and then the
other the third is outrage or insolence
or insult and the Greek terms for this
are
catafronesis
and one that you'll recognize hubris
right we usually think of hubris in
terms of like somebody being too big for
their britches in like tragedy they're
going up to the top and they have uh
over weaning you know whatever it is and
then they go down right but hubris is a
term that's used a lot in ancient Greek
with a lot of different senses
so what is contempt
when we're showing contempt for somebody
we are literally looking down on or or
thinking down on the Thrones right Kata
is downward and the phronesis is is
thinking or or estimating and so we're
considering people we're treating them
as if they have no value or little
values if they don't count for much so
that's one way in which we tick people
off right so despite is a bit different
this consists in placing obstacles or
hindering uh interfering with another
person and interfering with their their
path or their plans to what it is that
they wish for they desire they want
right so if you well you might get angry
with me let's say I'm your professor and
I'm kind of a jerk and you hand in all
your work on time and I'm like this is
totally unsatisfactory I'm gonna give
you an f and I'm going to make sure that
you know anybody when you take this
class again that you're uh you know the
professor that you take it with knows
what a terrible student you are right
that's that's malice or spite right
that's no longer like looking down on
you that's screwing with you and what
makes it different than hubris is that I
don't get anything out of it I'm doing
it just to screw with you to interfere
with uh what it is that you're trying to
accomplish and then we have insolence or
insult causing injury or annoyance to uh
do something to lower the status of the
other person just for your own pleasure
not to actually like gain financially
from it not because I'm motivated by
righteous anger or anything like that
just to screw with you to show you that
I'm better than you are that's that's
the motivation of hubris and Aristotle
actually uses an example from the
The Iliad and uh it's about Achilles
complaining about Agamemnon disgracing
him so if you've read The Iliad you know
if you've participated in uh the session
that we did uh what two months ago you
might remember that um Achilles actually
get so angry that he's ready to pull his
sword and kill Agamemnon on the spot and
he's perfectly capable of doing that
fortunately Athena says hey buddy uh
let's cool off a little bit here and he
he goes off and salks in his tent which
is a way of him showing his his anger he
feels that he has been uh slighted by
Agamemnon and he's not going to fight
for the Greeks until these things are
fixed so what do we got so far we've got
Aristotle's you know the importance of
his works then we got getting down to
the nitty-gritty the definition of anger
as once again a desire accompanied by
pain for a parent retribution around by
Apparent sliding against those oneself
or those connected to oneself the
sliding being undeserved and we got the
three main kinds of sliding contempt
Spite and insolence or injury
um so we've already got one question
lined up this is a great place for us to
take a few questions and then we'll
we'll talk a bit more about social
status and dynamics of anger so Mark
says
how would what Aristotle says about
sliding relate to what is meant
contemporarily when accused of being
offended is it the same thing where
there's snowflakes and Aristotle's time
yeah I mean there have been snowflakes
in every single time
um you know snowflakes being people who
are overly sensitive and liable to take
offense when
um no offense or less offense is
actually being directed at them and yeah
the ancient Greeks and we're going to
talk about honor in just a bit the
ancient Greeks were a very honor
obsessed culture I mean most ancient
societies tended to be and that hasn't
completely gone away it's been
transformed a bit I mean we don't
usually fight duels over honor anymore
but it's not as if this conception of
social status or clout or whatever we
want to call it just poof disappeared uh
with the the you know Vanishing of of
official dueling Society being replaced
by other stuff
um so when a person is being offended
now notice that Aristotle says this
apparent right you can take something as
being a slight that isn't a slight
um again let's use the example of
getting somebody's name wrong or their
title wrong right if you
um call somebody a manager when they're
really the director or a c-suite
executive a cool person will be like oh
man hey you just made a mistake a
prickly person will get upset about that
right people can get upset about just
about anything and so taking offense is
usually a sign that somebody thinks that
they have been whether they have been or
not slighted and I think that you know
is is this necessarily a completely
comprehensive list I don't know maybe
there's more to it than what Aristotle's
picking out but
these three types of sliding definitely
are you know important in our time
showing contempt looking down on people
screwing with people another way of
translating malice screwing with them to
just screw with them and then screwing
with them to try to get something out of
it to you know raise your own status
think about bullying for example genuine
bullying isn't spitefulness it could
stem from contempt right you you might
bully people that you look down on or
you might also bully people that you
think are better than you and you want
to lower them but it's it's motivated by
trying to get a good feeling
out of it on the part of the bullyer and
trying to impose pain or humiliation on
the bullied right
so any other questions about the
definition or kinds of sliding before we
move on and look at
um honor and and things that make us
more prone to be angry
what we can call
notable dynamics of human psychology
I'll give it just a minute in case
there's any uh questions people want to
bring up
see if I can fix the lighting a little
bit here too it's a little bit
inconsistent because it's a cloudy day
and so sometimes there's a lot of light
sometimes there's not
um
all right well I'm not seeing any other
questions so let's let's talk about
honor
um honor social status are standing in
society in relationships with other
people
um Aristotle thinks that's something
that we can often get mixed up about but
it's important to us and so
um Aristotle thanks that we're prone to
get angry at people who we think that we
ought to be valued and well treated by
so it's easier for us to get angry at
those who we view as inferior to us if
they're not treating us in the way that
we want so inferior in what ways could
be in terms of birth right
um now you know we're supposed to be all
egalitarian but that's not really the
case people do think that they're better
than other people because of who their
family is or their blood or their
nationality or you know pick whatever
else you want stuff that they have
actually no real control over you don't
choose who your parents are
um Power it wants people to actually
have uh power or authority you know like
a position a title
they think that other people
ought to be showing them respect and uh
treating them nice and stuff like that
um virtue you know actually being a good
person having good qualities to yourself
people who are virtuous do think that
they deserve
um to be acknowledged by people who
don't have that virtue so courageous
people by people who lack courage or any
other kind of superiority any other
imbalance
Aristotle gives you some examples here
the the prime one that he talks about is
rich people Aristotle is actually not a
fan of rich people you know he's a fan
of what we call the middle class the
people who aren't you know destitute and
poor the people who aren't so rich that
that's the thing that that they focus on
the most uh rich people tend to get
angry with poor people poorer people who
don't treat the rich people in the way
that they want to be you know
respectfully uh giving them nice things
sometimes giving them stuff for free
which is kind of weird isn't it if
you're rich you could certainly uh have
that uh BSO says can you tell us about
what Socrates thinks about wealth we're
not doing that here this is about
Aristotle so
um try to keep all your questions
confined to the topic that we're going
through uh he also talks about other
kinds of superiority so a good speaker
to a poor speaker somebody who's
eloquent to somebody who's not eloquent
Now isn't that interesting so this this
could be applied to anything where
somebody has talent or skills and other
people don't have it there's a tendency
among human beings to think well I
deserve more because I'm better in this
respect
um he also talks about people who are in
charge we talked about power he uses the
word
um Arco menos
um so those who rule over others and
this could be like you know your manager
at a office
um your boss they want other people to
acknowledge them for that and even go so
far as to talk about the person who's
worthy or thinks himself worthy to rule
over one only fit to be ruled and so any
of these can accentuate anger right
he also thinks that um we can get upset
with those that we think that we ought
to be well treated by literally we ought
to
um Suffer Well from people ought to do
good things for us so those that we've
done beneficial things for if they don't
treat us the way that we like we can get
upset with them quite easily especially
if we're still conferring benefits you
know you make a loan to a friend and
that friend doesn't uh help you out when
they're supposed to you you get angry
you think that they're sliding you
um and notice that this can also be
imaginary those that we desire to help
or did desire to benefit but didn't
actually benefit Aristotle is a great
Observer of the foibles of human
psychology then he goes on and talks
about a number of dynamics that are what
he literally calls the seasons you know
Seasons like spring and fall no he's not
actually going to say people are angrier
in summer or winter but he uses it as a
metaphorically Seasons times states of
mind diaphases and even ages of life
these things can make us more prone to
anger so this is sort of like General
human psychology so he says that
um you know in general people get angry
when they think that they or people who
matter to them have been treated
unjustly contrary to expectations of
good treatment when assumed social and
interpersonal Norms are violated great
example of this you go to a restaurant
and you see people being served around
you people come and take their drink
orders bring their drinks to them right
away and you're sitting there waiting
for your server to show up right and
you're like what the hell's going on
here right you like wave them over and
they're like hey I'll be right there you
know and then they come over and they
haven't even brought you your water yet
right and they're like okay are you
ready to order and you're like no man
take our drink orders and then we'll
talk about appetizers or starters right
and then they're like oh yeah yeah okay
sounds good yeah yeah and then you know
they go off again and you don't see them
for another half an hour now you're
angry right you feel as if Norms have
been violated
um he also talks about
um this is very interesting we can get
angry at a person
not for what they in fact have done or
um you know
are doing right now but what what we
assume they are likely to do or will do
so we get angry you might say in
anticipation you know if we go in and we
see the waiter who treated us bad the
last time and we got over it last time
and we're like oh that friggin guy right
I hope I'm not in their section we can
start to get angry
um people also get angry when they want
something and somebody else prevents
what they want or hinders them or even
fails to help them when they would
expect it
um and even bothering a person in a
state of you know unsatisfied desire can
make them angry so Aristotle uses a
whole bunch of examples with this
somebody who's thirsty can get angry
easier you've all probably seen the
Snickers commercials for Snickers candy
bars where a person you know is kind of
out of sorts and then they eat a
Snickers bar and they're back to being
normal that's what we call being hangry
it's a new term that has been developed
I think in the last 10 years or so
people who are you know trying to change
a flat tire on their car if somebody
everyone's Blowing by them they're like
these a-holes you know why won't they
help me you ask a stranger on the street
about directions to get somewhere and
they're like
tourist get the hell out of here right
you can get angry at them for refusing
to to help you and the more entitled you
feel yourself to be the easier it's
going to be to get angry at people for
not giving you what it is that you are
looking for right people also he says
get angry when events go contrary to
their expectations just like people when
things go well and they weren't
expecting it they're happy if things go
badly they're like oh man they get they
get upset and they may take that out on
other people and Aristotle actually says
the more unexpected it is the angrier
that they'll they'll get
one very common thing we don't like when
people ridicule us or mock us you know
they make fun of us or they scoff at us
when again let's take the tourist thing
somebody goes into I don't know a donut
shop and they're like I'm trying to find
this Museum here on the donut shop
person is like
that's scoffing right and actually if
you watch TV shows
um this is kind of funny we use closed
captioning quite a lot and you'll see
scoffs underneath because it's a thing
that we do uh not it's not non-verbally
I suppose because you do it by you know
verbal communication but you're not
doing it with words you're like oh
yeah that's that's scoffing right and
people have been doing that since time
immemorial apparently
um the other thing that I want to point
out that's really quite interesting and
I think a lot of us can relate to this
people become angry when what they value
or more literally what they take
seriously the Greek word for that is
spudazucine which means to be like
Earnest to be serious to be a a person
who prioritizes something
um when that thing gets denigrated or
treated contemptuously by others people
get angry
especially when people are insecure
about that like Aristotle says when you
don't really have the quality or the
skill that's being made fun of and very
interestingly the example that he uses
philosophy so you know when I was I I
come from a non-academic largely
blue-collar family and I would go to the
family reunion and people would be like
so you're studying what psychology and
then I'd get kind of miffed with them
because I'd be like no I'm studying
philosophy yeah right psychology isn't
that what you're studying and then they
would ask me things like so what's your
product how are you going to make a
living with this some people are going
to pay you to like read books is that is
that what's going on there you know and
I'd get you know I'd get upset with them
right because I felt like they were
putting down not me but the thing that I
cared about and we do this with any sort
of fandom if you're into a particular
band or a particular genre of music I
mean I see this all the time I'll give
you an example so I'm into classic 1970s
1980s heavy metal some stuff in the 90s
going forward I'm not into the genres
the big genres that sort of like became
where a lot of people's attention was
you know are you into death metal are
you into black metal are you into you
know blackened metal are you into folk
metal are you blah blah blah blah blah
right and my answer to a lot of that
stuff is no I'm I'm into the stuff that
was closer to the origin point and
that's what I listen to and I listen to
a few things in Doom metal or power
metal but I'm not really into that later
stuff and people will be like well
that's not right you should be listening
to this band or you should care about
this this genre and you'd be like
why the hell do you care about whether
I'm uh appreciating this band that
you're into I mean there's literally
tens of thousands of bands whose stuff I
haven't listened to I'm 52 years old I'm
probably not going to try to expand my
musical tastes to listen 24 7 to bands
that I've never heard of and people will
get very very worked up about that very
angry about that if you suggest to
somebody who's obsessed with I don't
know watching golf that maybe golf isn't
a real sport
that can get people worked up right so
this is this is a very common thing to
happen and Aristotle is noting this
Dynamic even back then
um
we'll talk about some some intensifiers
of anger and then we'll look at some
some questions so Aristotle also said
um
you know with this this thing that we
just noted people get more Angry if they
suspect that they lack the thing being
devalued whether they lack it entirely
or they don't have it to a considerable
degree or they don't seem to have it
they're not publicly acknowledged as
having it he also says that people get
more angry with their friends
um why do we get angry with our friends
because we expect more from them right
they that's what it means to be friends
we're in a relationship structure we
think that anybody should be treating us
well showing us respect to Fashion
consideration it's those people and so
if they're not doing it we we get angry
at them and maybe we also Aristotle
doesn't say this but maybe we also feel
a little bit more emboldened or secure
to get angry at friends as well we also
get angry at people that we consider
rightly or wrongly to be of little or no
value when they show sliding Behavior
contempt malice or insolence to us so
you know if I'm if I'm in the CEO of a
company and uh some guy in the mail room
is delivering the mail and he uh you
know I'm I'm talking I'm like working on
a report and he comes into my you know
office knocks on the door and he's like
just wanted to tell you uh boss uh
you're getting old and fat you know I'm
gonna get more angry at them than I am
if it's going to be like a middle
manager who's saying that to me because
I'm like who the hell are you to say
that to me right and you know so if
people again have a very entitled uh
attitude or think that they're more
important than they are they're probably
going to get angry at people very easily
Aristotle also says that we get more
angry with people who listen to stories
literally a queen they they hear uh the
stories of are bad things what's wrong
with us our faults our lack of talents
our mistakes or those who just like pay
attention to it they thought mods and
they they watch that and they don't they
don't do anything else uh the wit they
witness we could say our thoughts and or
are bad things and he says they resemble
enemies right
um he also tells us that if we get angry
at people and we're displaying that
anger we're engaging in that anger
um
and the person doesn't admit that
they're wrong especially if they want to
contradict us and say no no no you're
you're wrong about that who are you to
get angry we get angrier at them and I
think that's quite true
um he also says one thing that I I think
he's he's wrong about
uh he tells us that people are not angry
um when
um they are
um when other people are angry at them
right because then they are being justly
retaliated against I think that's
completely wrong
I think it's very common as a response
when somebody gets angry at us for us to
be like who that why are you angry at me
who the hell gave you permission to be
angry at me for this we take it as them
showing us a slight
um now if we do think that we are being
justly punished or retaliated against if
we actually buy into that I think that
Aristotle is right I just think that
he's overstating how often that happens
and then you know the the he also names
five groups of people in relation to
whom or in whose presence we get more
angry when we're slighted so one of
these is our Rivals people were on the
same level with it but we view ourselves
as being in competition
there's also those who we admire so we
look up to people though that we want to
be admired by so they're below us and we
want them to admire us and then those
who we
respect or literally have shame before
those whose opinions we actually care
about uh again higher than us and then
those who uh we think feel respect for
us when that happens so like you know
you're out you know for for dinner and
you've got your family along and your
family actually respects you and
somebody treats you badly you're likely
to become more angry
um he all says that there are situations
specific situations in which we're
likely to get angry as well more angry
with other people so when people slight
those who it would be shameful or
embarrassing for us not to protect or to
defend uh and he uses the examples of
parents children significant others or
spouses and then dependents those who we
rule over uh we tend to We tend to get
angry right why because
um we have a duty to take care of them
and they're being attacked by somebody
else
so we get angry in return
another those who are ungrateful
literally those who
um don't display or don't give back
horiz which is gratitude or even Joy so
you know if I do something nice for a
person and they're like oh that was you
know that was nothing that you did I'm
gonna get angry at them because I feel
like you you a-hole I did something good
for you I put myself out for you you
know
um
then there's there's a few as well those
those irony and Arrow's not a fan of
irony
um and he actually in other places we'll
talk about Socrates is not being a great
guy because he uses irony
um those who use irony when you are
Being Earnest or serious so those who
are you know kind of poking fun or just
not taking seriously what you're taking
seriously
um those who do good to other people but
not to you again the waiter who doesn't
serve your table but serves everybody
else it's easy to get angry because you
feel like they're sliding you and then
finally those who show forgetfulness
literally who forget things Lathan why
because this shows a lack of care being
indifferent to you Amelia right ah means
not and then the Malaya care a concern
so Aristotle uses the example of
forgetting people's names this is
something even in the present that will
tick people off so we see that Aristotle
is giving you an analysis of all these
different interesting uh Dynamics but
they do feed back into the definition
and the three main kinds of sliding
all right so let's take some of the
questions some of these are a little bit
um off topic uh you know should we be
wealthy According to Aristotle it's not
about being wealthy or not we should
have enough resources to take care of
ourselves
um if wealthy means being rich then
Aristotle says no if wealthy means
having adequate resources sure that's
got nothing to do with this
um duck with that wanting your pound of
Flesh because they didn't pay up yeah so
if if you're if people don't give you in
return what you expect from them that is
a sliding and you you might be wrong
about that like maybe you know you
didn't actually spell out the full terms
of the agreement uh and they didn't know
that they were supposed to do something
but that doesn't matter with respect to
the getting angry we can get angry
According to Aristotle for reasonable
you know grounds or unreasonable grounds
all that has to happen is that there is
a perception of sliding against those
who we care about or ourselves or things
we care about and that it's undeserved
it's unjust and we can get angry as a
result
um baso says uh why does he think we
feel angry instead of sad sometimes we
do feel sad he doesn't he's only talking
here and we're only concerned with here
people getting angry and and why and how
that takes place another possibility is
if somebody's mean to you you could feel
fear you could feel sadness but
here we're just talking about the anger
response and how that works another
question anger is part of the spirit
Soul there is no Spirit soul for
Aristotle
um you're thinking Plato instead and
what you're thinking of is thumos what
we often translate is the spirited part
of the Soul
um which you know isn't a good
translation really thumos is the part
with which we get angry for Aristotle
his anthropology as we started talking
about the beginning is a bit different
we have a higher rational part we have a
lower emotional part all the emotions
are felt in that emotional part whether
they're anger desire fear any any of
those sorts of things so any questions
specifically about Aristotle and these
dynamics of anger or the definition or
sliding or anything like that what we
still have to talk about is the opposite
of anger
um and how that works and then a couple
other remote emotions that are connected
with but different from anger
so any any questions comments
in the meantime I'll just remark that um
oh here we go
um
Max says would Aristotle talk about
getting angry due to anxiety of choices
so by anxiety of choices I imagine you
mean something like having to choose and
then feeling anxiety because of that
Aristotle doesn't talk about that
but
um being placed in situations that we
are easily frustrated in right it's sort
of like the
the dynamic that we talked about of
um being in need so need to make a
decision and then other people not
helping right or even making things more
complicated being like giving you
unhelpful advice for example
that would be so it's not one that
Aristotle talks about as an example but
that would be one where we could get
angry right
um so imagine a student who goes in to
see their their advisor about the
classes that they're going to take they
don't know what any of these classes are
and and their advisors like hey I I'm
not going to tell you what to do and
you're like well what the hell you're
the advisor advise me right and they're
like no no no I can't help you with that
sort of thing if you're a naturally
anxious person about those choices that
could turn into anger
um so yeah and and maybe uh so imagine
this right we have in our contemporary
Society what's often called the Paradox
of choice
which is that um
like going to the grocery store right if
you want to buy spaghetti sauce
um it used to be when I was a kid there
were like five brands of spaghetti sauce
and they you know there's Ragu there's
Prego there's maybe some high-end stuff
like Paul Newman and classical and
they're all spaghetti sauce right now
you go in and each one has got like
chunky and not chunky and with olives
without olives green pepper vodka sauce
you know you look at it and there's like
50 different kinds you're like well what
kind of sauce should I buy to put on my
spaghetti and if you're prone to anxiety
about choices I suppose that could piss
you off right because you're like
they've made it difficult for me to
decide what my optimal spaghetti buying
experience will be now if if you find
yourself in situations like that I think
Aristotle would say I think you need to
take a step back and realize that the
world is not trying to screw you into
choosing the wrong kind of spaghetti
sauce right so that would that would be
perhaps an example of that
any other questions or comments
um about Dynamics what intensifies anger
causes
um that sort of stuff
all right
doesn't look like there are so let's
talk about calmness so this is there's a
couple different words that he uses for
this prowse
as you notice there's the same like root
to it being calm
and this is very interesting because in
the rhetoric Aristotle likes to pair off
emotions against each other
and so you know like there's love and
hatred or
um fear and confidence and those are all
kind of like positive ends of a spectrum
right with this there's anger and then
there's like not anger being calm being
different than being angry and he
defines it as a quieting a catastasis
like a coming to rest or an appeasing a
literally making peaceful hemoresis of
anger so calmness itself isn't really a
positive emotion it's sort of like a
lack of emotion here right
and he says that What Makes Us what
makes a person calm well the opposite
things of what make people angry so we
we feel calm towards those who might do
something that we don't like but they
don't seem to be sliding us or if
they're doing so they're doing so
involuntarily like somebody you know
will take another Supermarket example
right you're looking at your spaghetti
sauces and somebody comes along and
they're kind of you know looking at
their phone and they uh they bump into
your cart and you're like hey what are
you doing there you know and they look
up and they're like oh oh oh I I wasn't
uh paying attention now you could get
angry and you could be like well you
jackass you should have paid attention
but most likely we're like oh okay and
especially if they do something like
they say oh oh my bad I'm sorry you know
and like let's say they they bumped Us
and something fell out of our car they
bend over they pick it up they're trying
to show us that they're they're taking
us seriously they're not sliding us well
we feel calm in relation to those people
unless we're screwed up with respect to
anger right so
um he also tells us that those who
behave the same way to themselves
so you know when we when we feel like
somebody's sliding us we feel like
they're placing themselves above us
right so if they for example uh let's
see let's use an example you go over to
a friend's house and
um oh I used to run into this all the
time when I was a kid so in my house we
didn't have a lot of candy and we didn't
have sodas and stuff like that so the
neighborhood kids we'd go over to my
house and they'd be like let's get a
snack and I'd be like well we got apples
and they'd be like apples
oh man don't you have any candy bars and
I'd be like no we don't have any candy
bars and they'd be like all right what
do you got to drink you got any soda you
got any juice and it'd be like we got
water tap water and at first they were
offended right and then they realized
that's the way our house is
I eat apples you know I drink tap water
I'm not like holding out the good stuff
for myself in the back yeah
um I I'm just giving him what I give
myself and then they were cool with it
they'd all they'd also be like yeah well
let's go over to Jeff's house or Jane's
house because there we're gonna get some
you know Hostess treats or stuff like
that don't go over to Greg's house
because his mom doesn't buy any of that
stuff
um but you know if if people see that
you are not
um you know putting them down then they
will uh generally not be angry with you
those who admit that they screwed up and
are sorry for it and they don't
contradict you or they behave humbly we
feel calm towards those
um people who show a proper degree of
seriousness when we're taking things
seriously who aren't joking around who
aren't being ironic we we view them as
you know behaving in the right way uh to
us he also talks about those who refrain
from insulting mocking sliding other
people anybody or virtuous people or
those who resemble us we feel
um like you know they're decent people
we don't get so angry at them uh people
who we also fear or feel respect towards
were less likely to get angry with them
Aristotle thinks that we can't feel a
lot of different emotions at the same
time and he's probably wrong about that
but there is there is one sense in which
like being you know afraid or respecting
somebody could like restrain our
feelings of anger
um and then you know if they think and
we talked about this before if they
think that that they did the wrong thing
and they deserve what they're suffering
as a result then they don't feel anger
because anger isn't aroused against
what's actually fair or just so you know
if a student for example
um cheats or plagiarizes and I catch
them at it and I you know the way it
typically happens they've plagiarized
from the net it wasn't hard to find I
just saw weird phrase I put it into
Google the page that they took it from
came off and I shoot them an email
saying hey you're getting a zero on the
assignment here's where you plagiarize
from it's against the rules don't do it
again or there's going to be stiffer
penalties sometimes students will get
upset because they feel that they ought
to be able to get away with it but if
they if they're decent people and
they're like oh you got me you know and
and thanks for being uh more lenient
with me because you could actually be
imposing some pretty heavy sanctions on
me
um they're not going to get angry if
anybody there are going to get angry at
them themselves not not at me right he
also points out one other thing with
calmness
so anger is kind of a let's say limited
quantity psychic thing
so when you're angry if you discharge
that anger on somebody else
you've only got a limited stock of it
now it's renewable you can always get
more Angry later on but when people have
taken it out on somebody then they're
less likely to remain angry with others
and he gives this terrible example of
the Athenians condemning some people to
death and then not condemning the next
batch of people who did the same damn
thing to death the next day which seems
you know kind of unfair they'd discharge
their anger against these these other
people and then he also talks about
um when we see people that we're angry
with and something worse happens to them
than what we were going to do to them we
stopped feeling angry and we instead
feel a different emotion which we can
translate as pity it's a typical
translation
or we can translate it as compassion
both of them are good translations
instead of feeling anger you know we
want to hurt them we're like oh crap
they're hurt enough a good example of
this right so somebody
um you're in a relationship
and they
um they break up with you because
they're like yeah I'm just not into you
man you know and you feel hurt and
because of that hurt uh and because
maybe you feel like they LED you on a
bit you feel angry at them and then you
know something terrible happens to them
like their parents are killed in a car
crash or um they go out on a date with
somebody else and they are beaten and
raped or they're just walking along the
street and they fall down an empty
manhole and break both legs as they hit
the ground I mean unless you're a real
rageaholic you're gonna be like oh crap
that's bad you might even like
go and help them uh after after what's
happening so this is you know these are
some good things to keep in mind there
are two other emotions that anger can
get mixed up with so we just talked
about the opposite of anger now these
are similarities one of these is what we
call hatred or enmity
um extra or misos in in Greek and
Aristotle is going to treat both of
these as essentially synonyms and the
other one is what we call righteous
indignation Nemesis now if you've if
you've seen that word nemesis before
it's usually like the person who's you
know going to seek revenge for the bad
thing that you did right these are
different than anger and I think this is
really
quite insightful on Aristotle's part I
won't say that I I want certain rain I
don't say I agree with everything that
he says about this but some of it I
think is is quite right
so
hatred he talks about he looks at what
causes hatred uh and anger is one of the
causes of hatred right we get angry if
we stay angry long enough we can start
to hate which is qualitatively distinct
from anger spitefulness can cause anger
but it can also cause hatred and then
the other thing that he talks about
causing hatred slander diabole right and
this could be like slander of different
groups oh can you believe what those
dirty people do and we start to hate
those those people if we grow up with
you know say racism or
um you know
despising people from a certain country
or with a certain religion or eating
that dirty kind of food or stuff like
that that can cause hatred that's
slander
so anger and hatred are different from
each other Aristotle says that anger
stems from acts that are committed
against us or people that you know we we
care about hate can arise from that but
it can also arise from all sorts of
other things just hearing that people
are bad people if we imagine that a
person is of a certain type we can hate
them and uh he also says anger is
against individuals you get angry with
Socrates you get angry with you know
um the person at the convenience store
down the street whereas hatred is
against entire classes again literally
types or races of people so he uses as
an example there thieves people who
steal we hate those bastards right and
this could be all sorts of things you
could hate people who are fans of a
particular sports team you could hate
people who live on the other side of the
railroad tracks from you you could hate
people who uh you know don't like rain
uh pick whatever you want right
um you could you could hate people who
drink certain kinds of sodas
any any we're very irrational creatures
so another thing that's different
between anger and hatred Aristotle says
that anger is curable in general by time
hatred is not
you know
anger will eventually erode itself you
discharge it
once you start feeling hatred that can
go on your entire life it can go on
literally forever
and then something that kind of puts us
in perspective what is anger about what
is anger looking for what's the desire
it wants to impose retribution it wants
to make somebody feel pain to suffer in
response I get angry at you because you
did something that I perceive as a
slight to me I want to make you suffer
hatred doesn't care so much about that
hatred wants to impose not pain but evil
Badness for its own sake and it can go
so far as to wanting the other person
the object of hatred literally not to
exist May Ani to not be in being and so
anger wants the person to to be in being
right you're gonna you're gonna do
something to them so that they can see
it and they know that it's you hatred
you know the Concentration Camp uh the
death camp is like a perfect expression
of hatred you want to eliminate the
hated object so that it it doesn't Cloud
up your perspective anymore so you don't
have to deal with it and then the last
thing that he says about
anger and hatred
I think you see how this can can fit in
here
um a person who's angry can still feel
provided they're not totally dominated
by their anger they can feel as we
showed just a little bit earlier
um
uh pity or compassion they can they can
literally feel that as I was saying uh
the person who hates doesn't have that
so these are some really important
distinctions there A lot of times people
in our culture are very sloppy about
confusing anger and hatred I think that
Aristotle is very good for explaining at
least some distinctions between them and
then the last emotion that we have to
talk righteous indignation or Nemesis
and he's going to say that this is the
opposite of pity
um why because it's a little bit of a
forced argument here pity is about
um feeling pain at somebody else's
undeserved pain right so I see you fall
and and you know crack your mouth open
and your teeth are falling out and
blood's coming out of your mouth and I'm
like oh man that must really hurt I'm so
sorry that happened to you all right
let's get you to the emergency room
that's that's pity you didn't deserve to
fall down and crack your teeth right
um Nemesis is the is the opposite it's
pain at the undeserved good that some
people get
so when somebody who just happens to be
rich is able to you know
um do things that other people can't and
have a great life well somebody else
lives a crappy life you know right down
the street from them Nemesis is this
sense of that's wrong you know and it
can it can lead to action just like
anger can or hatred can
um and he says that you don't feel this
to people who are just or courageous or
virtuous why not because they deserve
good things right and as a matter of
fact both pity
and Nemesis or a righteous indignation
Aristotle says there are signs of a good
character as opposed to Envy which is a
sign of a bad character
so
what do we feel this about you know
advantages like wealth or power or other
good things that good people deserve and
mediocre or bad people don't and we can
we can extend this he says to Natural
advantages like you know being born in
the right family or a physical beauty or
strength or stuff like that right
um and he uses as an example the newly
rich
and he says that people get indignant
with those who recently acquired
um their their you know their um riches
and who owe their prosperity to that and
so they you know like buy public office
with their their wealth they're not good
people they're not necessarily bad
people but they sure as hell don't
deserve what the good people deserve and
aren't getting and he also goes so far
as to say if a virtuous person doesn't
get what they deserve right then we also
feel indignant we're like well what the
hell you know you're you're letting this
schmuck over here who just happens to be
like you know from a famous family or
has a lot of you know followers or they
got a lot of money you're giving them
good things but you're not given this
genuinely good person over here good
things this is wrong right now it's not
the same thing as anger because there's
no sliding of yourself going on it's
more other oriented that's how Aristotle
distinct English is this anger you feel
because you feel like you've been
screwed or somebody close to you has
been screwed this is more you might say
um
unattached to you as an individual so we
could say it's I don't want to say
egoistic versus altruistic because
that's not the right terminology here
but you could say that it's more public
spirited right or we could even say it's
more objective if you wanted to so these
are the the emotions that Aristotle
thinks it's important to realize are not
the same thing as anger but you notice
that they're kind of similar right and
they lead to similar things retaliating
against people
now there's a couple uh questions here
um
how can we control this desire meaning
anger I'm guessing right because because
uh hatred is not a desire so much as
Aristotle says although I suppose it is
desire for the other person not to exist
uh how can we control this desire
According to Aristotle so two answers
um one is we're going to talk much more
about that next session when we look at
the moral aspects of anger right
um the nick of McCain ethics and the
Damian ethics and all that but we could
we could easily say If you think about
what we've looked at so far and you read
the rhetoric and you understand how
anger Works knowing how anger Works can
help you control it right because you
can think about the definition itself
you can be like all right so anger is a
desire arising from the perception of
sliding or imagine sliding oh wait a
second
was I really slighted there or am I
imagining it right that that's one way
to learn to control it if you know that
you have a tendency to get angry in
um the presence of certain people well
then when you're in the presence of
those people and you find yourself
getting angry you can say oh wait a
second Aristotle actually gave me some
clues about this so that that's part of
the answer to this but there's there's
other things that we're going to look at
next uh session this is more about this
isn't so much about anger control this
is about understanding anger but you can
take the stuff for the understanding and
you can look at it as the mechanism and
then you can you've got the levers in
the mechanism don't you that you can
work with
um what about anger about one about
oneself like in Temperance I assume what
you mean there is you get angry with
yourself not about yourself but with
your own self for being in temperate
right
um well you know Aristotle doesn't talk
about that here because again this is
the rhetoric we're thinking about uh how
do we communicate persuasively you can
and again in other works you can be
upset with yourself
for being vicious like being in
temperate like you go to the buffet and
um you're you know you're like man I'm a
fatty I need to quit eating so much and
then you're like but it's you know
special day and I I did actually like do
this this thing so I'm gonna celebrate
I'm gonna go to the all you can eat
buffet but I'm gonna be temperate I'm
not gonna like eat like a pig uh the way
I did the last five times I'm gonna like
uh keep myself within proper bow I'll
let myself have two plates of stuff and
a soup and a dessert one dessert not
three you know and also I'm not gonna
drink I'm not gonna like go up and you
know drink a gallon of soda I'm gonna
keep myself in there and then you go in
and they're like you know you forget
yourself and an hour later you're like I
can't believe I ate so much you're
looking at this pile of plates and
you're like oh damn it in temperate
again right
uh now you could get angry at yourself
over that right in order to do that
so what Aristotle says about
um
committing Injustice towards yourself
you have to be able to look at yourself
in two different ways in order to do
that
you have to be able to say like the
higher part of myself got screwed the
lower part of myself got over indulged
right
um that's that's how that could happen
and so the better part of yourself could
be angry with the worst part of yourself
that's that's as close as Aristotle can
get to that he doesn't he doesn't talk
about getting angry with yourself much
which you know that might be a gap in
his treatment we don't expect any of
these philosophers or literary thinkers
have the perfect
um theory of it we just want it to be
good and cover a lot of stuff
um
kashar says I blame the American
proportions of soda yeah I mean American
proportions of just about everything are
pretty excessive right they're not
particularly good
um BSO says sometimes we have no other
choice than anger like I want to eat the
cake but it's unhealthy so I eat it I
feel bad and if I don't I feel angry
because I can't you don't have to feel
angry I mean telling yourself that is
lying to yourself and covering up the
fact that you do control to some degree
what you think and feel I mean this is a
key thing in virtue ethics in general
whether it's platonic Aristotelian stoic
Epicurean any later virtue ethics we
don't we can't snap our fingers and
automatically not feel something but we
do shape our characters so if if you
don't want to eat the cake you don't
have to feel angry because you didn't
get to eat the cake you can feel all
sorts of things you can feel sad you
could feel you know like you're missing
an opportunity you don't have even have
to feel anything you can just think
things like it would be nice to have a
cake but I'm not going to have a cake
right so you don't have to feel angry
um and that's that's one of the good
things about
virtue ethics in general it's very
liberating to realize that we do have
some measure of control over our own
feelings and what we do with them so
um you know if if you're having trouble
not eating cake and you're you know
you're able to impose self-control but
you feel angry every every time you do
that rather than Feeling Just pained or
sad
you probably want to look at your
relationship with anger and why that's
the the go-to rather than these these
other emotions you know and you know
whether you want to be stuck eating big
pieces of cake and feeling bad about it
the rest of your life I mean you don't
you don't have to be
um that's that's where developing
Temperance is a possibility for us so uh
we got about 10 minutes left oh uh here
we go
um
cash bar uh can you name a few
philosophers after Aristotle that have
written about anger there's literally
thousands of people that have written
about anger and many of them are people
that we're going to be talking about in
future sessions you can see in the video
description you know who's coming up
this year one of those philosophers is
going to be Seneca whose book on anger
we're going to be looking at epicurus
talks about anger
um all the stoics Seneca Marcus Aurelius
Epictetus talk about anger Cicero talks
about anger Plato we talked about Plato
already but he's not before Plutarch
um really all these important virtue out
this is talk about anger and it goes
through the Middle Ages goes on to
Modern Times Renee Descartes talks about
it and on the passions of the Soul so
you just got to kind of like look around
to see who's actually getting at it
Thomas Hobbs talks about it uh
um David Hume Emmanuel Kant you just
gotta like read through their texts and
you'll find discussions of the emotions
and then discussions of of anger all the
way down to
present-day psychology which by the way
is often not as good as what's going on
in ancient virtue ethics
um max says what would be one major
difference between Aristotle's Dynamic
of controlling or looking at our desires
versus cancer Dynamic on inclinations or
desires at least with respect to hatred
I mean I I don't even know what you're
asking there
um both of them think that we have
capacities for looking at and
controlling what it is that we feel
um
so I I don't see there you know dynamic
isn't the word I would actually uh use
there because neither of them are using
that
um they have different ways I mean
Aristotle thinks obviously is a virtue
ethicist if you develop the virtues one
of which is is control has to do with
anger good temper
um you know
um
that's good Kant says well it's the Good
Will so I mean if that's what you're
looking for
maybe that's an answer to that you know
I mean but both of them think we have
freedom and can choose
how are psychology is is developed and
constructed
um
B so should we learn a skill According
to Aristotle and Socrates because it's
not real knowledge that's a whole
different issue that's not connected to
this Jose even Homer talks about anger
with Achilles trying to accept
agamemnon's power yes we did an entire
session if you've been you know looking
at this again look at the video
description we did an entire session
about The Iliad starting with you know
uh tell me oh Muse about the Rage of
Achilles right so
um
yeah I I think you can you can go
through the the sessions and and find uh
some some in-depth discussion of that so
any other questions comments uh things
about Aristotle and anger that you want
to
inquire about bring up
the um
coming sessions will be
[Music]
um
well the next one is Aristotle some more
right and so some of the things that
people are looking for some
clarification will will get more about
how we
develop ourselves if we want to into
less angry people
um and then we are going to be looking
at
um several other writers
um including
um
let me uh bring it up I don't have it
top of mind oh yeah so next in in
September and October we'll be looking
at Ashley's uh Sophocles and euripides
and then November is epicurus and
lucretious so Epicurean philosophy and
then December is Seneca on anger and
then after that
um we will be starting a new year and
we're going to move into more ancient
authors
um you know some more literature some
more uh philosophy we might get to some
Jewish and Christian authors by the end
of the year uh we'll see there's a lot
to to go through so we'll see how we get
there
um
all right I don't see any further
questions so maybe we'll wrap up here
and uh
we'll we'll say see you next time more
Aristotle coming down the pike
um wouldn't hurt to take a look at what
he says in the rhetoric and then uh the
nick of McCann and the ethics the
politics particularly book five where
he's talking about social breakdown or
status as anger is one of the causes of
that so anger has political dimensions
for Aristotle that you might find quite
interesting so I'll see all of you next
time and uh we'll continue on with the
series
foreign